people of the internet retrorecord tour
here and we have some absolutely
massive news to discuss today regarding
the future of
avalanche wb games hogwarts legacy and
oh so much more
earlier this week at t announced they
were planning to
spin off warner media and merge the
company with discovery in a deal that
will have
far reaching impacts across numerous
franchises across television
movies and games but how does this
affect hogwarts legacy and the question
i know you all have on your minds but
may be afraid to ask
does this mean the game will be canceled
look there's a lot to unpack here and i
think we need to start with an overview
of the situation on a broad scale
because guys
i can't stress enough how huge this is
in the world of media this is much much
bigger than just hogwarts legacy and i
know it can all be very confusing for a
lot of people there's a lot of business
lingo being tossed around so i'm gonna
do my best to help simplify things for
you as much as i can
now i mentioned in the opening at t is
essentially selling warner media to
discovery they call it a spin-off but
for our purposes here just think of it
as a
sale and it is a massive sale worth
around 43 billion dollars for a t
yes you heard me right there 43 billion
unfortunately for a t they spent 85
billion to acquire time warner just
three short years ago
if the discovery deal becomes official
which it's not yet more on that in a
second
their plan is to merge with warner media
to form a brand new company
there's not yet a name for this new
company so for our purposes today in
this video let's just call them
dw for short and that will make things
easier for our discussion here because
it is going to be a completely new
company discovery
warner media merged to form what we're
calling dw
in fact the announcement did mention
that discovery's current
ceo david zaslov will lead the new
company which means warner media ceo
jason keller is probably on the way out
the new york times has reported that he
is currently working on an exit package
now
hogwarts legacy fans will certainly
recognize the name jason keller because
it was just a few short weeks ago
that he tweeted out four pieces of
concept art and we discussed those here
on the channel
so that really just goes to show you how
fast things can change i mean he was
just tweeting out pictures for hogwarts
legacy hyping up the game talking about
how excited they were
and now today he appears to be on the
way out
now i mentioned that this was not
official yet and that's because this is
all still subject to regulatory approval
and
also approval from shareholders so it's
not 100 official
anytime there are big deals like this
with major major businesses
there are certain procedures these
companies have to follow and then
ultimately the government has to okay it
in fact some of you may remember nearly
a decade ago when at t announced their
plans to buy t-mobile
but this eventually hit a snag during
the regulatory process and it never
ended up happening
all that being said at the time of this
video recording both at t
and discovery have agreed to the deal
and are moving forward with this plan
so barring any snags there the merger is
expected to become official
sometime in 2022. on a broad scale the
core focus for this merger appears to be
an effort for dw to compete
with streaming giants like netflix and
disney plus as brian stelter of cnn put
it the move will quote
combine two treasure troves of content
including the hbo max
and discovery plus streaming services
close quote you see discovery owns
channels like tlc the food network
hgtv and plenty more warner media of
course owns
their fair share of major ips as well
such as dc comics
hbo cnn tnt and of course
harry potter at least a portion of harry
potter anyway as for how it seems right
now it would appear that
all of those ips will be under the new
umbrella of dw once the deal is made
official next year
okay hopefully you're still with me so
far because now we need to talk about
warner brothers
interactive entertainment now this is
where wb games falls under and that is
where they come into play so as part of
the overall
warner media they'll likely be moving
under the direction of the new company
right well that's where things get a
little
murky according to ign's julia alexander
she's been told by a t
that part of wb games will be sold off
warner brothers interactive
entertainment owns 11 different
development studios here they are
on the screen right now they also own
two publishing labels
one of those being portkey games and as
we all know these devs are working on
some pretty significant projects at the
moment
so what happens to those projects like
hogwarts legacy like gotham knights like
future mortal kombat games what happens
with the studios
alexander would go on to speculate quote
there's a good chance that a lot of
those will continue
especially if they bleed into warner
brothers top ip
other studios might not work on games
with one-to-one ties to warner media ip
for example tt games works mostly on
lego games
warner media doesn't have close ties
with lego universal does
if you're looking to sell some studios i
imagine you start there
close quote now i always keep things
honest keep things real with you guys
here i'm gonna give you my true opinion
on these things and i have to say i'm
i'm gonna be honest this all makes me
very uneasy there are still so many
unknowns so many what-ifs so i think our
first step is to find out what's
happening with avalanche and it really
seems like there are only two
possibilities here possibility one is
that they'll be part of the sale
and under the new dw company and if
that's what ends up happening the new
company
could leave things as they are at least
for a while or they could decide to
completely alter and change things
the other option is that avalanche could
remain under at
t and be sold off separately now some
people seem to think that they could
stay under at t and just remain exactly
as is but that is not how i read the
information that we've gotten so far
i think any of the studios that quote
unquote remain with a t
would likely be sold off separately
because it really doesn't appear like
at t wants to be involved in the whole
media business at all anymore
they took a shot at it they lost
billions of dollars and decided nope
this is not for us so now they're trying
to help pay back some of the debt
okay all that being said i think
avalanche does have
a few things working in their favor
right now first off this game has been
in development for quite some time and
is hopefully nearing the finish line
in fact it's entirely possible the game
ends up releasing before this merger
even takes effect
avalanche is also working on a game
under the harry potter ip and the harry
potter franchise will of course be
moving to the new company as alexander
of ign speculated she would guess that
the game's tied to major franchises with
ties to warner media like harry potter
will continue
now i don't want to be too pessimistic
here but even if that is the case what
alexander speculates there there's still
a chance that at t
and wb could make changes in preparation
of the sale of the move to the new
company
a lot of people don't seem to think the
game would be outright canceled because
of the money that's already been
invested but
personally i don't see that as a strong
argument namely because
this is a billion dollar deal
guys remember 43 billion dollars
cancelling this game and even outright
closing studios like avalanche would
honestly be just a drop in the bucket of
that massive sum of money that we're
talking about here
i think one of the strangest scenarios
would be let's say avalanche is
sold off separately but the harry potter
ip
of course remains with our new company
dw now whatever company avalanche
maybe sold to and then the new dw
company i think they would be able to
work something out to at least
finish the game you would expect that
when they put this much time and effort
into it it's
hopefully again close to the finish line
but here's where the curveball
comes in what about post launch support
what about any possible
dlc down the road my opinion today and
it is just that guys it is an opinion
this is an ever evolving situation
things have changed quite rapidly
already so this could all change by the
time this video gets out
but my opinion right now if i had to
guess is that hogwarts legacy will
end up releasing in 2022 but i do worry
about
two things number one avalanche's future
and number two post launch support for
the game
it certainly seemed like avalanche was
planning something really big here i
mean they had all these new hires
including a community manager i think
this was going to be a game with support
for quite some time
now if i had to lay out what i think
would be a best case scenario here
i think it would be for avalanche to
actually stay with wbie
which means they would move to the new
dw company and hopefully that new dw
leadership will just say hey
we like what you guys are doing just
keep doing what you're working on
they'll get to continue on their current
projects their current goals and maybe
even give some post-launch support
as well now this certainly is not going
to be the last
video that i make on this undoubtedly
this is going to come up again and again
so i want to hear from you guys in the
comments below
what questions do you all have about
this i still have so many questions as
well
in a deal this massive there are just so
many moving parts these changes won't be
able to happen overnight but you can
rest assured changes
will be coming guys they will be coming
to wb
avalanche and honestly even the harry
potter franchise as for how much
we'll have to wait and see now if you're
new here and you're just checking out
the channel for the first time we have a
ton of hogwarts legacy content i'll link
you to a playlist here on the right side
of your screen now so you can check out
all those videos
as always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon